Kenneth Walker was charged with
attempted murder of a police officer
after the Raiden March but those charges
were later dropped he is now suing the
Louisville Metro Police claiming
misconduct joining us now is Steven
Rines one of Walker's attorneys thank
you Mr Rines for joining us this morning
I want to start with the attorney
general's findings that the police were
justified in shooting because they say
your client shot first what do you say
to
that uh well in every other situation in
Kentucky a justification of self-defense
is determined by a jury and it should be
in this case as well when we we start
letting elected politicians determine by
prosecutorial Fiat who should be charged
and who who shouldn't then we are going
down a a very dangerous road that it is
it is the exact opposite of way our
Criminal Justice System should work and
unfortunately it happens often times in
in police shooting cases um that the
prosecutors say well the police was act
were acting in self-defense the police
do not have any higher right to
self-defense than any ordinary citizen
does in Kentucky yeah because Stephen
wasn't isn't your client saying he was
acting in self-defense when you listen
to his 911 call he clearly didn't know
that they were police
officers absolutely not and that and
that is why the case was dismissed
against him was that he was acting
reasonably acting in self-defense and
he's in his own residence so he has a
presumption that he's acting in
self-defense we've got a dozen neighbors
who were interviewed by police as well
who said they never heard the police
announce that they were police there's
no question they were beating on the
door but they never announc his police
attorney general Cameron said well the
the two police said they uh announced so
we're going to start taking the the word
of the the targets of the
investigation as as
exculpatory they also said Stephen they
also said they also said they had a
witness who who said that they heard the
police say announc themselves and that
witness that witness Gale was
interviewed by the police 3 days after
this happened initially and he stated I
did not exact words did you hear them
Ann announce his police he said I never
heard anyone announce his police he was
subsequently interviewed two more times
over the next month by law enforcement
lmpd law enforcement and he eventually
says yeah I I yeah I may have heard them
announced they were police in fact I saw
a uniform police officer that's after
the shooting had already occurred there
seems to be some confusion too Stephen
about the ballistics in this case what
do you know about
that what the ballistics I know the
ballistics done by I know what the
ballistics done by the Kentucky State
Police show and that it was whether or
not Kenneth Walker shot hit Sergeant
madingley it was inconclusive uh I've
got the documents and attorney general's
got Cameron's got the documents as well
but I I don't know why he wants to to to
play these games about talking about
small portions of the evidence and not
releasing the entire file release the
entire file and let people make their
own decisions which is the same thing of
indict them apply the presumption of
innocence apply their rule of Reasonable
Doubt let them go to trial and if
they're quitted like everybody else fine
but do not by prosecutorial Fiat say
they're innocent they're exonerated and
I'm going to to decide they don't get
prosecuted well there is still thing
about it is Gail yes yes sir is the the
the issue of self-defense justification
in Kentucky law does not apply when you
kill a third party if they're acting as
self-defense on Kenneth Walker as they
claim they don't get to kill Banna
Taylor as well all right and that's the
law so so him telling us what the law is
in Kentucky that's not the law yeah
Stephen step rindes there are so many
questions in this case all of it very
upsetting but what we do know it's also
not okay to shoot at police officers in
the streets you know the the violence
has got to stop violence on top of
violence on top of violence will get us
nowhere but I really really thank you
for taking the time this morning many
many questions remain no problem